des décollages spatiaux il en a connu
deux Michel Tonini est l'un des neuf
astronautes français avoir été dans
l'espace en 1992 vers la station mire
avec un équipage russe dans un vaisseau
Soyuz et en 1999 sur la navette Colombia
mettant en orbite le télescope Chandra
dans le premier vol russe'était un rôle
de des expérimentateurs scientifique
médical avec principalement une
expérience sur l'échographie et sur
expérience neurosensorielle alors que
chez les Américains j'étais plutôt
ingénieur de bord pour le déploiement du
télescope Chandra c'est un sentiment
assez étrange parce que vous voyez la
terre d'une façon particulière comme on
l'a jamais vu vous voyez les étoiles
avec toutes leur couleurs vous voyez
toutes les étoiles sans aucun frein
atmosphérique ou nuageux vous voyez le
ciel qui est noir vous voyez les
planètes comme on les a jamais vu pilote
de chasse pilote d'Essé et astronaute il
est aujourd'hui président d'une école de
pilotage à temp Michel Tonini va aussi à
la rencontre du public amateur et
passionné pour la plupart étudiants très
intéressant on a pris beaucoup de choses
parce que c'est vraiment une personne le
métier d'astronaute c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit pas tous les jours c'est à la
fois un rêve mais c'est c'est vraiment
le domaine dans le lequel on travaillit
c'est c'est notre c'est notre métier en
fait ici une très belle expérience alors
c'est c'est quelque chose de très
spécial parce que déjà c'est pour moi un
rêve d'enfant pour aussi je pense
beaucoup de monde euh parmi les
étudiants qui ont assisté et c'est
quelque chose qui non seulement r la
motivation mais aussi permet de voir le
leé vraiment le côté vraiment concret de
de ce métier parmi les 450 auditeurs
peut-être de futurs astronautes le 15
novembre prochain un 10e voyageur
français partira en virete
spatiale